I will take another caller 2617 830 for
750 is the number who's on next with us
david sagar I'm from Chicago Illinois
great to hear from you what's on your
mind I wanted to though I just saw a
video of yours uh from yesterday
regarding I guess in pennant media and
the role that um I guess this is really
about the corporation's having kind of
an oligarchy uh uh uh I kind of
connectedness to the idea of having
independent media that doesn't
necessarily rely on sponsors or
corporate sponsors at least and instead
relies on I subscribers I'm just like
for example he owes a lot to be
broadcast anything they like because uh
you know they're golden to their
subscribers and not to other interests I
want to ask you what do you see the role
of uh you know that shows like you know
you show um for example other shows
include the written report um and
there's many others online on YouTube
but I wanted to hear your thoughts on
kind of where this is headed and what
kind of role it could potentially play
in and larger society well independent
media has grown drastically because of
Technology right if it weren't for the
internet high speed internet and all the
different sort of uh internet
technologies that we take for granted
today this show couldn't exist a lot of
the shows you're talking about just
could not exist because there was such a
high barrier to entry you either had to
build a radio station for millions of
dollars and set up a broadcast tower
where you had to get hired at the TV
station or something like that it was a
really really high barrier to entry so
might my uh hope is that as technology
becomes a democratizing force that will
have more and more programs now the the
counter to that or the concern always is
when you lower the barrier to entry it
can be harder to discern what's quality
in what isn't quality but the the
internet reputation economies upvotes
and down votes had these things do have
a role to play and they can help us sort
of figure out what should float to the
top uh so I'm I'm hugely bullish on
independent media as I'm sure you would
guess based on the fact that that
what I'm involved in yep that's actually
really great um I actually only
discovered your so very recently um
after watching you on the urban report
and I think you've done a great job I
actually didn't know that you better
have 23 years but I've seen it a few
here more recent videos and I think
they're very spot so like to thank you
for your work well thank you so much
really appreciate hearing from you and
it's always good to get the rare rare
compliment rare positive call uh when we
take live calls let's see about maybe
taking one more call if we have it the
number is 6 1 7 8 30 for 750 people
think we screen calls only only a
negative calls are cancelled and not
allowed to come on but the truth is any
topic is always welcome at 6 1 7 830
4750 however there are no more calls
today and that's okay we took a few
phone calls we will call it a day and of
course take more calls next week
remember this is you viewer supported
media you can sign up for membership at
david pakman.com slash membership
gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / tdps the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com / tdps